In the last two classes we've had judges
tell us that good faith means different
things in termination cases then in
formation cases or in cases where there is
discretion in the midst of
a contracts performance.
Well today we're going to be
looking at a termination case.
We're looking at a 1980 Massachusetts
case entitled Zapata Versus Dairy Mart
where the court considered how the duty
of good faith applied to an at-will
termination clause in
a franchise agreement.
Yeah.
In this case, the Patho purchased a
franchise from the defendant dairy mart,
an operator of a chain of franchise
convenience stores as Epatha relied on the
representations by dairy mart that the
franchise business would be his own
stable and secure.
The franchise agreement allowed either
party to terminate without cause on 90
days written notice when plaintiff refused
to sign a new agreement modifying the
terms of the franchise defendant sent
written notice that the franchise was
terminating support.
The sued claiming the
dairy marts termination was
dishonest and in bad faith the
trial court found for the Zapata
but the instant court reversed.
The central issue is this was dairy marts
arbitrary termination of its franchise
agreement with the Zapata in
valid because of bad faith.
Okay.
And the court answered?
No.
The court found that the franchise
agreement was not terminated in bad faith.
The court turned to the UCC
as adopted by Massachusetts,
which says that good faith
requires among merchants quote,
honesty in fact and the observance of
reasonable commercial standards of fair
dealing and the trade unquote the honesty.
In fact a requirement of good faith
is a bit redundant with fraud.
So most of the action in these cases
will be about whether there was an
observance of reasonable commercial
standards, a fair dealing.
The court held that quote,
there was no evidence that dairy mart
failed to observe reasonable commercial
standards of fair dealing in the
trade in terminating the agreement.
And it also found that the termination
may have been arbitrary but it was not
dishonest.
Next,
the court pointed out that although the
legislature had limited the rights of
certain franchise doors to terminate
franchise agreements without cause,
it quote has not adopted limitations
on the right to terminate all franchise
agreements in general.
Finally,
the court declined to rule that all
at-will termination clauses are invariably
prohibited and accordingly ruled that
dairy mart lawfully terminated the
franchise agreement
in another part of the,
the court considered the plaintiff's
additional claim that the termination
clause was unconscionable. We talked
about unconscionability and pass classes.
What's the difference between procedural
and substantive unconscionability? Well,
you should remember that procedure.
Lung conscionability concerns
the how of of the contract,
how the contract was negotiated and
whether the bargaining disparities allowed
one party to take advantage
of a more vulnerable party.
Substantive unconscionability
concerns the what of the contract,
whether the resulting terms
were substantively unfair.
One side at the court in Zapata Hell that
the contract was neither procedurally
nor substantively unconscionable.
The plaintiff was specifically shown the
termination clause prior to signing and
later testified that it was quote
straightforward unquote and the plaintiff
failed to show that the clause allocated
the risks and benefits of termination
in an unreasonably disproportionate
way or that the clause was unreasonably
related to legitimate commercial needs
in Zapata dairy mart reserved broad power
to terminate the franchise without cause
and followed the clause to the letter
in exercising that power.
The court looked at whether dairy mart
acted in good faith when exercising that
power,
but if terminating because the franchisee
refuses to modify the franchise in
terms more favorable to the
franchisor is not a bad faith.
What is well suppose that the franchise
or discriminated against a minority
franchisee or suppose that the
termination was in retaliation because the
Franchisee had reported salmonella in
the ice cream to state health authorities
or suppose the purpose of the termination
was to capture a thriving franchise
for the benefit of the
president's brother in law.
Any of these reasons
might have been bad faith.
Federal and state statutes
have increasingly regulated
the power to terminate a
franchise relationship.
One example is the automobile
dealers day in court act,
which provides that a dealer may sue
an automobile manufacturer for damages,
quote by reason of the failure of set
automobile manufactured act in good faith
and terminating,
canceling or not renewing the
franchise with said dealer.
Good faith, however, is
narrowly defined as quote,
the duty of each party to guarantee
freedom from coercion, intimidation,
or threat of coercion or
intimidation from the other party.
Termination clauses are relevant not
only for franchisees but also for at-will
employees.
For more than a century,
American courts firmly adhere to the
view that an employment contract of no
fixed duration was terminable at will.
This means that an employee could
quit or be fired for any reason,
good or bad, or even no reason
at all. In recent years,
both judges and legislatures have
significantly limited employers powers to
discharge employees.
Legislatures have adopted
statutory protections and
judges have developed common
law. Limitations on the ability of
employers to fire employees at will,
especially limiting the
ability to fire for bad reason.
An employer will be liable if the
employee terminates for a variety of bad
reasons,
including race and gender discrimination.
Tort law allows a cause of action for
wrongful discharge based on making the
employee making public policy
claims from being a whistleblower.
And in 1991 the national conference
of Commissioners on uniform state laws
formally approved the model
employment termination act.
Although as of now,
no state has yet adopted it.
Let's review.
Today we've considered an at-will
termination clause and in a franchise
agreement,
and looked at a case where a court
held that an honest Albay it arbitrary
termination of a franchise agreement in
accord with the contract terms was valid
and not in bad faith.
We also discussed the trend
away from at will employment,
at least in the sense giving the
employer the right to terminate for bad
reasons.